what's going on everybody my name is
alex freeburg and in today's video we're
going to be starting our basics of sql
series now in this series we're going to
be going over everything you need just
to get started and then in future videos
we're going to be going over some
intermediate concepts and some more
advanced concepts and then in the final
series we're going to be going over some
portfolio projects
so to download sql server management
studio we actually have to download two
things and i have both links right here
i'm going to leave those in the
descriptions that you guys have those
but this one is to actually download sql
server management studio so let's go
down here i actually deleted it off my
computer so i can walk through this with
you guys
so we're going to download that let's
also go over here
this is actually a server so we have to
download a sql server and if you go down
right here
there's a free version now i don't need
the developer version i'm just going to
down the express version it's actually
smaller so let's download that as well
now once this is done running we're
going to open it up and i'll show you
what to do next
so it just finished running let's click
on it
all right so we need to install it
we're going to click yes and this is
going to take a little while
so this popped up i clicked install and
it's been running for the past couple
minutes apparently i was not recording
so i apologize for that but that's all i
did
so now it's been installed i'm actually
going to pull it up right here
and let's open it up
now when it pulls up it's going to ask
you to connect to a server and that's
why we downloaded the sql express server
so let's connect to
that and there you go it's as easy as
that so now we have sql server
management studio set up and we are good
to go
so the first thing that we need to do is
actually create a database so let's go
over here to databases and let's click
new database
and let's just do
sql
tutorial
keep it simple
and if we click that it's going to
create our database for us now when you
open up the database there's going to be
a lot of stuff
you really do not need to know all this
really what we're going to be sticking
to is this tables right here
as of right now we do not have any
tables so we need to create tables now
there's two ways that you can do that
you can click right here and you can go
to new and create table
we're not actually going to do that
we're going to create it using a script
or t sql so we're going to go over here
and do new query and we will get started
on actually creating
the two tables that we're going to be
using for all the stuff going forward
all right so let's get rid of me because
we really don't need to be seeing me
anymore let's get started by doing our
very first table which is going to be
our employee demographics table
so let's start off by saying
create table and we have to name it so
let's do employee
demographics and enter down we want to
do an open parenthesis now we need to
specify what our column names are going
to be and what the data type is for each
column
so let's start off
with employee id and we want that to be
an integer so that'll be like 1 2 3 4
anything numeric
now we want to do
first name
and let's make that varchar
50. if you don't know what these data
types are that's okay
that will probably be covered in a
different video that's not really
necessary for this video
let's do last name we'll also make that
varchar 50.
let's do age
make that an integer
and
very last let's do gender
and we will make that
varchar50 as well
so
now we have our very first table
let's run that
and we'll see if it works we'll go over
here and we'll refresh our tables
and there you go so we have our very
first table
let's go up here let's get rid of this
one and now let's create our second
table
so we're going to do basically the exact
same thing but we're going to have a
little bit different information in it
this is going to be our employee salary
table
so let's do
create table
and again we need to name it
and enter and open parentheses so now
we're going to do the same thing we're
going to do employee id
let's make that an integer
now we want
the job title
because we want to know what they do
and this one is going to be
varchar
50 because we keep it pretty simple
whoops
and then for our very last one we're
going to do salary and that will be
integer as well
and i'll just do here so let's create
this table
let's see
if it is there
and there we go
so let's open up one of these tables
really quick
see what's in there see what it looks
like as you can see we do not have
any information in there
when you create a new table sometimes
when you open it up you're going to see
this if you want to get rid of that you
just need to
do a i think it's called a hard refresh
or something like that but you can do
control shift r
let's see if it works for me i just did
it all right and it goes away so now it
recognizes it as a table
so we're good there
let's go back here
and let's get rid of all this we've
already created our tables
now we want to insert the data into our
tables so let's see what that looks like
let's do insert into and now we need to
specify what table we're inserting our
data into so let's start off with
employee
demographics
let's do values
so now we have to select what values
we're going to put into
into this table
so now we're going to have to do the
employee id so let's do 1001
and then we'll do first name let's do
gym
last name
halpert and then his age let's say he's
30
and he is
a male
now just for fun
let's execute that
let's go back to this table right here
and execute
and as you can see all of our
information actually went in there so
now we have his employee id
his first name his last name age and
gender now
we need a lot more information
for this table in order to actually
learn a lot of the concepts of querying
the table
so i'm actually going to go through and
add a ton more information i'm not going
to bore you through that but i will show
you the final product before i actually
hit execute so stick with me i'm
actually just going to cut to the end
where i insert all my stuff down here
and then if you want that i'll probably
leave it in the description or maybe put
in my github or something so you can
easily just go copy and paste that if
that's what you want to do so i'll see
you in a few
seconds all right so i have all my
values right here i actually want to
take this one out because i already did
that one
but this is our additional information
let's insert that into our table real
quick
and go back here and take a look at it
and there you go this is going to be our
core information that we are querying
off of
in future videos so that table is
completely finished let's go back here
we're going to
get rid of this because now we want to
insert our information to our other
table so let's do insert into and let's
do employee
and now we're going to do salary
so
let's do values to specify that we're
inserting values into there
and in this one we have employee id so
again let's do 1001 that's jim
his job title
is salesman
and let's say his salary is 45 000
and let's execute that
and you can't see it but down here it
says it's done let's go to that table
and as you can see that is inserted i'm
going to do the exact same thing as i
did before i am going to fill out all
these and in a second it will be done
on your side and then again i will leave
it in the description or i'm going to
put it on my github and you guys can
just copy and paste that if that's what
you want to do or you can write it out
whatever you want to do
all right just like before i'm going to
get rid of this first one that is jim he
is already done now let's insert this
information
it is finished let's go back here
and there we go
let's just get it started by doing
select
everything
and let's do this from the employee
demographics table so let's execute this
if we wanted to only show the first
names we can just do first name
and run that
and if we want first name and last name
we can just separate that by using a
comma
and it will return those
well if we want to return all columns in
all rows
then all we have to do is use this star
so that's what the star does
now we have nine rows of data here and
if we only wanted to return let's say
the top five we can easily do that and
we can just say
top
five
of everything now the reason this could
be useful is say you have a table that
has millions of rows in it and you only
want a small sample
you can say select top 1000 and when you
do that it will only select the top five
rows
now let's get everything back in here
really quick because we're going to move
on to this distinct feature so
when we use distinct we're actually
saying that we want the unique values in
a specific column so if we say
distinct
and then let's do employee
id everything should be returned so all
nine rows should be returned and that's
because
every single one of these are unique
now let's try gender
so there's only going to be two results
the male and the female and that's
because there's only two distinct values
in that column
now let's look at all of our data again
so now we want to look at count now
count is very simple all is going to do
is going to show us all the non-null
values in a column
so let's look at last name for example
if we do count
of last name
all that's going to give us is a count
of nine because we have nine last names
if for whatever reason somebody's last
name was left out and that was null
then it would have returned maybe eight
or seven depending on how many were
actually in there so if an entire column
was null it would be returned to zero
and if you notice we are not given a
column name that's because this is
derived information based off the last
name so if we want to actually give this
a name so that that column does not say
no column name
we can use this as right here
so
once you put as you can actually name it
so since this is the count of the last
name we'll write last name
count keep it simple
and if we execute that as you can see we
have last name count right there so
that's how you use that
as
let's look at all of our data again
we want to look at some max mins and
averages right now and
the only column here where it would be
useful to do it on is age
but let's actually go over and let's
look at our salary table
and at our salary table we have some
really interesting salaries that i think
would be a little bit more useful for
this information so let's go over to
employee salary
all right and let's look at this table
really quick so we have our salary
now we want to look at the maximum
salary
that is in
that column and that is going to be 65
000
now let's say we wanted to know what the
minimum salary was
let's execute this and the person who
makes the least money is making thirty
six thousand dollars now what's the
average what is the average salary for
all employees
that's gonna be forty eight thousand
five hundred fifty five dollars so so
super easy to use all of these things
they're extremely useful i use them
every single day so i know that each of
these are very very useful and are
definitely among the basics that you
have to know
let's look real quick
at everything really quick
so we just learned the select statement
but learning this from statement really
quick is also important
up here this actually shows us that
we're already hitting off the sql
tutorial database but let's say we
change it to master when we try to run
this it's going to give us an error and
that's because now we're getting off
this database and this database does not
have this table in it
so in order to do this in order to still
hit off that table while up here we're
actually hitting off a different table
we can change this information so
the from statement you have to specify
three separate things the first thing
that you need to specify is the database
so let's say we want to hit off the sql
tutorial database
now we want to select what table we're
going to do
this is actually a dot dbo so let's put
dbo there's
there's a lot that can go into that it's
not worth getting into now but
dbo dot and let's do employee salary
when we execute this our information
comes up even though up here we're still
hitting off the master database when we
specify it right here
then we actually are choosing what
database and what table to hit off of
and so it does not matter what it is up
here so that's how you use the from
statement
now what does the where statement do it
helps limit the amount of data and
specify what data you want returned we
have quite a few concepts that we're
going to be covering today let's just
start out with something really easy
let's do
where
first name equals
gym
really simple
so we're selecting everything where our
first name equals jim and this is our
output so really really simple let's try
where it does not equal this right here
says does not equal jim
and let's execute that and as you can
see we have everybody except jim halpert
in there
so now let's look at the greater than or
less than so in this table i think the
one that we're going to look at is age
so let's look at age
and let's do where it's greater than
30.
and when we execute that we're going to
get everyone who is over the age of 30.
now as you can see we're not including
people who are 30 years old if we want
to include people who actually are 30
years old we're going to add the equal
sign right there
so we should be seeing people who are
now 30. so before pam and jim were not
in there and now they are
if we do the exact same thing let's do
less than
32
here's everyone that's going to be
included but if we want to include the
people who are 32 year old
then we are just going to add that equal
sign and now the people who are 32 years
old like toby and meredith are now
included
if we want to go even further we want
people who are less than or equal than
32
and
who are male
we can say where gender
equals
male
so now we have two things that we are
specifying that we need we need someone
whose age is less than 32 and we need
their gender to be male
so let's execute that and we have four
people who meet that criteria
so that's what the and statement does
if we write or
then only one of these criteria has to
be correct in order for it to be met
so if we hit execute
now we're saying anybody who's under the
age or equal to 32
or their gender equals male so if we
look down here michael scott is actually
35 years old so he's over 32 but since
he is male he is now included let's get
rid of everything really quick i want to
look at this like really quick so let's
execute just that and if you do that you
highlight just that and hit execute then
it will only run what you have
highlighted so now let's look at this
whole table
now when you're using like you typically
are doing this for
sometimes numerical but most time using
it for text information
so if we're looking at this right here
if i'm looking at last names
and let's say i want
everybody whose last name starts with s
you can't really do that with anything
else so i'm going to say where it's like
and then i'm going to say s
and after that i'm going to put a
percent sign that's actually called a
wild card and if i close that off what
this is saying is is i want every last
name where it starts with or where it's
like where it only starts with an s
so let's run this really quick
now we have two people whose last names
start with s
now if i put a wild card at the
beginning we are now saying where there
is an s anywhere in anybody's name
so let's execute this and see what we
get
so now even if the s is like flenderson
towards the end it still counts
so you can specify multiple things in
here as well so let's say i wanted to
start with s
that would return schrute and scott but
now i want something that also has an o
in it so so it has an s at the beginning
and somewhere in there there's an o
now let's execute that and there's only
one person that meets that criteria so
you can do that for multiple things you
can even say
ott and let's execute that and he's
still going to be returned
and if we put c at the back
it's not going to be returned because it
follows it in order
so it isn't s o t t c
the c would actually need to go
over here
so now we have s-c-o-t-t
and although there's a bunch of wild
cards in here it is going to return
scott so that is a little bit a little
hint at how you can use like there is a
little bit more that goes into it you
can use it for numerix
there's a lot of things that you can use
this for but this is just the basics how
you can use it today how you can get
started on using the like in a nutshell
that is how you use like and as i said
before you can use like with numerical
data as well but for demonstration
purposes i wanted to use text data
let's get rid of this really quick let's
look at our entire table
and i wanted to show you how to use null
and not gnome i can't really show you
how to use null because i do not have
any null fields i could easily update
this table and make one null but that's
in a future video where it's a little
bit more advanced where you can start
altering your data but just for purposes
of showing you what nolan not null is
let's do
where first name
is
null
and if we see that it's not going to
return anything but if we say is not
null
it's going to return everything because
nothing in here is null nothing in this
first name column is null so that's how
you use it there are a lot of use cases
where you actually will use nolan not
null that will be in future videos
probably in the project section or the
portfolio section we weren't able to
show really how to use this super well
but just as a demonstration that's
really all it does it looks at the whole
column and whether it is null or not
null that's really all it's used for
this is actually super useful and you
can use it in a ton of situations but
again for demonstration purposes that's
really all it does
so let's get rid of this let's look at
in really quick
so n is kind of like the equal statement
but it's multiple equal statements
so let's say
we want to say we're first name
equals
jim
and then we were like wait we also want
to include michael scott
so then we would have to write and where
first name equals and then we would do
michael and then etcetera etcetera for
anybody that we wanted to include but if
we said in we could do an open
parenthesis
and then we can say gym
we can say
michael
and we can say as many people as we want
going down the road just separating it
by commas and if we hit execute
everything would be returned so it
really is just a condensed way to say
equal for multiple things
so that is the where statement i think
the where statement can get extremely
complex but this really is highlighting
the basics so if you can learn all of
these concepts you will absolutely have
the basics down and will be set to go
over some more intermediate and more
advanced things with the where statement
later on
the group by statement is similar to
distinct in the select statement in that
it's going to show the unique values in
a column the difference is
is if we say distinct
gender
what's going to be returned is the very
first unique value of female and the
very first unique value of male
but
if we say gender
and we say
group by
gender
it's only going to return two values
but in these two values we actually have
all the males rolled up into this one
row and all the females rolled up into
this one row now let me further show you
what that means if i say
count
of
gender
now you can see that this whole time
there were six males in this one row and
there were three females in this one row
so with the distinct it really is only
showing us what value is in there that's
unique but with the group by it's
showing us what the unique value is but
it's also rolling them all up into one
column so that we can use it for other
things
now real quick i want to be able to see
both of these at the same time so let's
just put
this up here and let's run this so we
can actually see both
now let's add age to this statement down
here or this query
and let's only run this one and i want
to show you what happens and why it
happens
we're now looking at gender age and then
the count of gender
so if we look down here we only have one
male who has 29 we have one male who is
female that's age 30 and so on and so
forth so
none of these people
are both the same gender and the same
age
if for example we had two or three
people who were male and who were 30
years old then we would have a 2 or a 3
over here
so this count is actually being counted
at each row that's being returned
so
for our data that we have today this
isn't a fantastic example because it
really split it out there any that were
the same but as you can see you can put
multiple columns as long as you put
multiple down here
now why did we not have to put this
count gender down here in this group by
that's because this count gender is
actually a derived field or a derived
column it's derived based off the gender
column so it's technically not a real
column that's in the table it's one that
we're creating that's fictional
per se
so the age and the gender are actual
fields or actual columns that are in our
tables they have to be down here and
like i said before it's the comparison
to that distinct in the select statement
because we're looking at the distinct of
gender and age so we're saying distinct
across multiple columns both gender and
age now as we had before we were only
looking at gender
it's going to roll all those up into
just male and female but if we want to
add more we can easily add more in this
group by statement we can still do
things
like where age is greater than
31.
we can still do those things so
let's execute this and our number is
going to change now we're doing it based
off gender
and we're looking at the count of people
whose age is greater than 31 which is
smaller than before now let's look at
order by i'll do it down here really
quick for demonstration but i am
eventually going to come up here and use
it because i think it'll be a little bit
better to completely round out this
query down here
let me give this a name let's do count
of gender
and then let's come down here and let's
order by
let's order by
count gender
and when we run that it's going to do 1
3 and that's because as a default
sql has an ascending feature which is
going to be smallest to largest going
down if we want to change that we can
change it to descending that's going to
be largest to smallest so now we have
three one
and if we want to do it based off
gender and we do it descending now we
have z to a
and so that's going to be male female
and if we get rid of that it's going to
do the default ascending
and let's see what that brings female
male now
for what we're trying to do let's look
at this large table so i think it's
going to be a little bit more
descriptive or a little bit better
visually
let's do order by
and let's do age
let's run this and it's going to order
smallest to largest
if
we do descending
it's going to do
largest to smallest
now you don't only have to do just one
thing
you can do multiple columns so if i
wanted to do
age and then gender i can do that as
well so let's do gender
and let's run that so now we have the
age but under the age we also have it
ordered by female and that's in
ascending order so a b c d f so females
first so it's going to be female first
and then it's going to be male
and again female and male
now we don't have to just let it be
ascending for each one
if i wanted to do it reverse in this
column
i can do descending
now let's run that and we have 30 now
male is first and female second
and if i wanted to do that over here i
can do descending
and now we have them both descending so
it's going to go top to bottom and when
we have 32 it's going to be male 32
female
so you can specify
lots of different things in here and we
don't actually have to use column names
we could just use numbers so if i wanted
to do 1 2 3 4 5 i could
but let's try to replicate the exact
same thing before this would be column
one two three four
so let's do
where four
descending
and then let's do five
descending
and if we execute that it's gonna give
us the exact same result as if we'd
actually put in the column name and i i
do use this a lot often times i don't
use the column name i just if it's a
small table i'll just use the number so
in my actual queries i do this a lot
where i just use the number instead of
the column name so that is the group by
and the order by statement and if you
have walked through my previous videos
you should be completely done with the
basics of sql so congratulations the
next thing to do is really just practice
the basics because the basics are what
you're going to be using day in day out
and so what i would recommend is create
a few more tables query those tables try
to think of use cases and what you would
actually want to know from that
information after that i would move on
to my intermediate videos if those are
already out and then i would move on to
my advanced videos those are going to go
over some more challenging topics but
things that would be very useful for
anybody to know
in my next video i'm going to be going
over intermediate sql topics things like
joins and subqueries and a ton more so
if i already have posted those be sure
to go check those out on my page
and if i haven't i hope to have those up
soon thank you guys so much for watching
i really